Thank you everyone.
I'm glad you are still here and
have some energy left for the last two talks.
I'm
starting this slide empty because I want to
ask you
something first.
The next slide will have a riddle on
it, and I want to ask you if you already know
this one,
please don't shout the answer out loud, just
let
everyone try and figure this out by themselves.
So be
quiet.
It is a bit depressing, but I hope you can
read
it.
A father and his son are in a car accident,
the
father dies at the scene and the son, badly
injured, is
rushed to the hospital.
In the operating room the
surgeon looks at the boy and says, "I can't
operate on
this boy.
He is my son."
Just read it and I'll give you ten seconds.
I'm not
giving you the answer.
Oh, you're super quiet.
That's
nice.
My name is Lieke, I'm from Amsterdam and I
notice
there are a lot of cat pictures at this conference,
so
I added one a black cat cycling through Amsterdam
on an
orange bike with tulips.
What more do you want?
You probably know me, maybe not, maybe not.
I'm
involved in the real skills summer of code,
also a Dutch
ambassador for the code week, if you don't
know, Google
it and participate, because it is awesome.
I have my
own website called codepancake.com, where
you can find
a lot of resources on coding and I'm proud
of the
spotlight series, there are a lot of amazing
interviews.
I work at an organisation on girls and women
in
science and technology.
Our mission is to involve the
increasing of girls and women in science,
mathematics,
engineering and IT.
We do research but also organise
activities throughout the education chain,
so primary,
secondary and higher education.
You can see four role
models.
We have a large database with over 2,000 female
IT professionals and students, and I think
that is
amazing because we can always count on them
if we have
activities.
But the question is, why are we doing this?
Why do we need more women in tech?
Well I think Brenna
already mentioned it a bit, but diversity.
Things in
more general in diversity have proved to be
more
innovative and creative and effective in teams.
If
you're interested in this project, go online,
there are
lots of resources online.
And another thing, the lack
of women entering the tech field is also a
loss of
talent with the IT industry, and a loss of
opportunity
for the women and entering the job market.
So a lot of
talent is wasted, actually.
Girls and females are underrepresented in
tech, if
you compare them to the male counterparts,
and in the
Netherlands it is somewhat exceptional because
we are
last, actually Tunisia is below us, and then
the
Netherlands.
Less than 10 per cent of the females are
working in IT and in the Netherlands, and
you can see
Germany is below average for the 35, and we
have
23 per cent, and the rest of the European
Union is 37.
So why is this?
Well, the choice for science and
technology by Dutch girls is far below the
average, like
I said.
Well, it is true that brains of boys and girls
are not the same.
But these differences is not the
reason why there are many more boys choosing
a career in
tech, because both of the brains are full
with
potential, but to what extent, the potential
is for
fields and which is highly dependent on stimulation
that
parents and teachers offer.
Next is also that girls think they perform
worse
than they actually do in STEM related subjects.
I'm not
sure what your grading system is, but in the
Netherlands
it is from one to ten, but if you have a 5.5
then you've
passed your exams.
We always ask students if they think
they're good in mathematics, and boys normally
raise
their hands if they have a six, because it's
good they
passed our test, right?
And girls are more like: no, I
should have eight or nine.
So they're too hard on
themselves and it is not necessary at all.
Secondly, environment, like I said, girls
are less
stimulated by teachers and parents to choose
a career in
IT, and this is a cartoon, I don't think you
can read it
but it is a teacher, and he says: "Well, your
child is
has very good grades in maths and science,
but she's
a girl."
And then the parents reply "Oh shit, that's
too bad."
So that's not an option to consider a career
in IT.
Last but not least, there's unfamiliarity.
Girls have
no good image of STEM medications and professions
and
there's a huge lack of role models.
So I just want to
conclude this with a quote, it is from unlocking
in the
clubhouse, very early in life computing is
claimed as
male territory at each sustainable early childhood
through college, computing is both claimed
as guy stuff
by boys and men and passively ceded by girls
and women.
Question observation shows that disinterest
and
dissatisfaction are neither genetic nor accidental,
nor
inherent to the field, but are the bitter
fruit of
external influences.
This is important because if you think there
are
less girls in IT because of disinterest, then
you're
wrong.
One of the external interests is unconscious
bias.
Evolution has taught us to mathematically
process
information without critical thinking, so
we're
constantly overlooking much of the world around
us and
there's actually nothing serious about this.
We receive
11 million bits of information every day,
and we can
only consciously process 40 bits.
The conclusion is
stuff gets broken while our brain is storing
information, and our objectives are certainly
clouded
because our brain is taking shortcuts and
relies on our
earlier assumptions.
So even a tiny bit of bias can
have big consequences, for example, these
biases can
prevent introduction of diversity into workplaces.
I think this is a great example.
Blind auditions.
I just add another picture of a cat behind
the curtain,
because that's the way it is supposed to be.
Laughter].
Well, it is a research from Princeton, and
they
found other that since the 1970s the number
of women in
orchestras went up from five to 25 per cent,
and due to
the fact that they asked them to audition
behind the
screen or curtain so they couldn't see if
it was a male
or female.
So I think that is -- well, that's a lot of
bias going on right there.
Well, most people would agree that gender
bias
exists in others.
All of us, myself included, are
biased.
So you should take a look around, I think
you
know the cartoon, maybe.
A guy says, "Well you suck at
math" and then a girl has to answer wrong,
and it's like
Girls suck at math."
If you're curious about your own biases, you
can
take the implicit associations test, it is
called
project implicit from Harvard University,
and it
measures actually how quickly words like math
and
physics are associated with boys or men, you
can also
take this test with a career and family, but
this is
a gender science test, and I took it, and
I have to be
honest, I worked in IT, I've been a developer,
and these
were my results.
So it says "Your data suggests
a strong automatic association of male with
science, and
female with liberal arts."
So yeah, I just added that, because it's also
something you should do, and I felt terrible
because
I work in IT and I should have known better,
right?
So
this is something I should take home.
Now it gets me
back to the riddle.
I think you know the answer by now,
probably, I hope.
So who is the surgeon?
You can
shout.
Yeah, the mother.
It is true.
Actually, two
days ago I learned that in German "surgeon"
is a female
word, so it could be that most of you already
know the
answer right away.
I don't know, but in English and
Dutch it is different.
In 80 per cent of the time, it
is when we ask or tell people about this riddle,
they
don't know the answer.
Or they are more likely to think
that it is a gay couple, or that the father
is a step
father, or that they magically live again,
but nobody
thinks it is the mother.
This is true.
I have to
admit, I had it wrong the first time.
So don't feel bad about it.
Don't feel bad about
being biased, because it is just the -- because
of our
culture that we're biased.
So, notice not about football.
But yeah, when it
comes to implicit and explicit associations,
the
Netherlands are highest in gender stereotyping
because
a lot of -- I think a couple million people
took the
test, and you could fill in your country and
these were
the results, and I think that is shocking
because
I always think of the Netherlands as modern
and open
minded, and well, it turns out it is quite
-- we are
quite old-fashioned when it comes to gender
stereotyping.
So I was shocked, and I decide to take
a look around, and I notice some things.
I think you
all know the girl and boy department at toy
stores,
yeah.
Well on the left it is pink, it is advertisement
for girls, so you learn a bit of Dutch now,
and on the
right it is boys, it's blue.
This is actually for the
girls, it is a dish washing set.
I don't know why, it
is a stupid gift anyway because nobody likes
doing the
dishes, right?
But yeah.
[applause].
It is pink.
It has a pink sink, it has a real
working tap, it is like amazing.
And on the right is
for boys, it is a microscope, it has 23 parts,
it has
glasses, everything.
So these are associations, and you
come across them when you're already 3 years
old or
something.
This is another one, that's also induction.
It's from a children magazine.
It is a test, and it
defines who you are, and on the left, it is
for boys of
course, because it is blue, it says, "What
are you?"
Well, the results are: you are a tough guy,
you are
a smart guy, or you are a funny guy, and on
the right it
is pink, and it is for girls and it says,
"You are
a sweet girl", and the description is horrible.
It
says, "You think about others before you think
about
yourself.
That's amazing."
Okay.
Second -- well, you're a sporty girl, and
third you are [Dutch], which is non-translatable
which
means cosy, fun to be around.
I think it is a bit like
a German word, if I pronounce it right.
Gizelle(?).
Okay.
Well.
Anyway, I think this gender bias could be
a major threat, and it is a major threat,
because it is
one of the key reasons why few girls study
computer
science.
The good news is bias can be weakened.
The
bad news is you cannot do it alone.
We should all do it
together.
So, what should we do first?
Well, be aware that
you're bias, because believe me, you are.
Just take the
test when you have time, and you learn about
your biases
and how you can address them.
Second, I think it is important, use inclusive
language.
Because a couple weeks ago I was at
a conference, a Dutch conference, and it was
about the
future programmer, and someone got to the
stage and
started talking about the future programmer
and he said:
well, he is this and he is that, and he should
be this
and he should be like that.
And I felt offended, come
on.
I am obviously not a future programmer then.
So
I don't think he meant it that way, but it
is good to be
aware of what you're saying.
I think this is from
a social media platform and they removed the
word
hacker" from their job titles, and they noticed
the
change in who was applying.
So they decided to write an
article about it and how gender inclusive
they were,
they attached an e-mail they sent to the employees,
and
the e-mail started with "Hi guys".
It is not very
gender inclusive.
So just for some people this is
offending, so just be aware of what you're
saying.
Well, this is important.
If you're male or female,
doesn't matter, hold yourself and others accountable
and
point it out, because by the simple act of
talking
openly about behavioural patterns it makes
the
subconscious conscious, so talking transforms
minds
which transforms behaviour and communities,
and which
can result in a better environment, for example,
women
in tech.
So we should all share this and talk about
it.
Last but not least, use your imagination.
Counter-program your brain.
I Googled for "programmer"
and these were the results I got.
I really like the
right one, below it says, "Do not wake up
a programmer,
he is working, not sleeping."
It is important,
important lesson.
But you can only see one female and
there is a black guy and the rest of them
are all white
males.
And I think you should be aware of the images
you have in your head.
If I ask you to picture an
architect or programmer, I think most of the
time it
will be a white male with glasses or something
like
that.
Just be aware this is not always true ... I
think
you probably all know this one.
Hashtag I look like an
engineer.
I think this a great way of bias busting.
It
started with this girl, she works at 1 lodge
Inn, and I
don't know if I'm supposed to say that, but
she was an
advertising campaign for a company, and they
were
looking for developers, and then she got a
lot of
responses on her picture like "oh, I didn't
know that
you were an engineer.
You don't look like an engineer"
and so on.
And she was a bit fed up and started the
hashtag actually, and she asked everyone to
spread the
word.
And I think these are all engineers, you should
remember.
This is some great bias busting, like I said,
and it is a great way of breaking down gender
stereotypes.
So in short, be aware that you're bias.
Use inclusive language.
Hold yourself and others
accountable and use your imagination.
So counter
programme your brain.
I know we are at JSconf and it
should be about coding and programming, but
the thing is
it is not about the programming, it is about
the way
you're programmed.
I know it has been a challenging day
today, but I'd like to ask you to take this
home and to
look past your initial perceptions, because
I bet you
they're probably wrong.
So thank you.
[applause].